tonight what I really want to do
is tell you about
my friend Barack Obama
a leader
who has what it takes to lead us over
the next four years
he likely didn't know it at the time but
Barack didn't feel quite the same way
and the book doubled down about the 2012
presidential campaign it was revealed
that former president Obama seriously
considered replacing Joe Biden with
Hillary Clinton as the number two on his
ticket the thinking was obvious Obama
saw Hillary not Joe as The Heir Apparent
and would set her up for that 2016 run
well it never happened but it is
relevant to the current predicament Joe
Biden finds himself in
he's old and he's frail and his number
two is widely despised
enter Gavin Newsom now consider that
Newsome has been positioning himself
lately traveling to Red States pulling
desantis-like moves in his State like
going after a school board and finding
them for not accepting his radical new
curriculum running ads all of that
while some in Democrat circles have been
salivating over his replacing Biden that
was never a serious play
replacing Kamala though
who says no
consider this piece from The Wall Street
Journal today
where's Kamala Harris
plan to campaign extensively for
President Biden's re-election but her
early schedule suggest otherwise
so is something afoot joining us now is
Chris Bedford executive editor at the
common sense Society
Chris this just struck me today and kind
of watching things playing out in
California I mean it is interesting that
Newsome is taking on that Temecula
school board for refusing to accept this
radical new curriculum that they want to
put in place in the public schools there
involving you know all sorts of topics
that we've covered on the show he's
trying to kind of do a DeSantis in the
reverse in California and meanwhile
Kamala seems like how low can she go we
don't know because but low
yeah Gavin newsom's really set himself
up in the tradition of California is
sort of the the experimental lab for for
left-wing ideas and things that we like
to make fun of and scoff at but 10 years
later find themselves federal policy
affecting all of us or afflicting all of
us is more like it but I the the reason
why I think in the end Barack Obama
didn't go with Hillary Clinton despite
the fact that he knew that she was the
air success his parents successor
despite the fact that he would never end
up backing Joe Biden after uh for
president at least at least in the race
right after is because when you switch
your vice president it portrays an air
of weakness and Joe Biden's campaign
especially given how weak he actually is
both physically and in popularity in his
own party is not really going to want to
I think portray any more weakness than
they already have a Campbell Harris
brings nothing Chris Chris let me just
jump in Chris let me just jump in on
that I'm sorry to interrupt but in this
I mean you're comparing Obama one of the
best political campaigners that we've
seen in the last 50 years to Joe Biden
who can't find his way off a stage I
mean
I mean I don't know I don't know if you
can compare those two in this at this
juncture in their campaigns I mean Biden
needs all the help we can get at this
point in my view
that's true but remember Obama was weak
on re-election the economy was bad his
his poll number was bad about his
polling is bad the percentage of people
who thought the country was going in the
wrong direction made it look like Mitt
Romney had a really good chance to
unseat him as president that turned out
to not be true in the end but with Joe
Biden I think one of the big things they
want to do is have this theater pay no
attention to the man behind the curtain
portray an error uh an aura of strength
right here so while Kamala Harris
doesn't add anything to the ticket you
have to wonder what would Gavin Newsom
add maybe he would invigorate some of
the left Wingers but a lot of the folks
that look at his technocratic California
and say that's the future I want for Cal
for this for this country might already
be on Biden's side yeah Chris Kamala is
not going to go down without a fight if
anyone's thinking about replacing her on
the ticket well listen to her today we
are imperfect
and we must be honest about that to
understand then our history where we've
been and then have a North star in terms
of where we must go
oh my God Chris
she cannot be the future of the
Democrats she could she could be a
crossing guard though she has the good
hand motions down
I mean there's so much buyer's remorse
from Democrats and it's because she was
a hire that just fit uh the diversity
quotas as opposed to someone who
actually brought a lot to the ticket and
worse than that she hasn't done her
homework she's she's an absolute
nightmare as a principal for her
staffers who I'm sure are working really
hard to make sure she has more than a
few just nonsensical lines to repeat
like maybe explaining what artificial
intelligence stands for she does no good
but in the end of the day if she if
anyone wants to replace her she's going
to call them sexist she's going to call
them racist and this is something that's
very frightful to the Democratic party
even if Republicans at least have
finally learned to not care about those
kind of insults unless she gets a great
job at let's say Google or Apple just
saying all right Chris hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else